das gab es noch nie bei gckum doch
natürlich im Interview mit de Kind das
Glücksrad diesmal auch wieder erhebliche
Konsequenzen sportliche Betätigung
kommentiert mal bitte wie pork Philip
und feris kommt noch dazu sich schlagen
außerdem im Fragen Lotto die machen ja
eine riesen Bühnenshow aber eigentlich
würden sie auch ganz gerne woanders sein
das verraten sie jetzt im
Fragenlotto das ist das
Fragenlotto da sind nette Fragen drin
und gemeine Fragen die sind auf euch
zugeschnitten die gemeinen Fragen sind
rot die netten frag sind grün ihr könnt
blind ziehen ihr könnt gucken wie ihr
wollt oh grün kann ich eine rote haben
natürlich kannst du eine rote haben nimm
eine rote tu die grüne wieder reinemine
einfach abdrehen die Enten die Enten
einfach abdrehen die Enten abdrehen wir
gehen nämlich auch gleich zum Asiaten
abot essen und dann dreht auch die Enten
wurde den Enten auch der Hals abgedreht
Achtung
Mikro ich lese das mal vor eure Musik
erinnert stark an die 70er und 80er ist
euch nichts Neues eingefallen also unser
neuer Produzent Roy der der ja mit das
Album mit produziert hat der der hat mir
das tatsächlich auch immer vorgeworfen
dass ich immer mit Beats ankommen die so
80er mäßig sind aber irgendwie ich kann
da einfach nicht gegen an das ist
einfach meine Zeit und auch so also 70er
ist auch tatsächlich so eine Zeit wo wo
ich gerne draus gesampelt habe immer
früher und so weiter und da komme ich
bin ich irgendwie zu Hause Hamburg ist
auch tatsächlich so eine 70er Jahre
Stadt ich habe auch jetzt gerade wieder
im lefun wieso ist das eine 70er Jahre
Stadt
sonst was irgendwie also aber es gibt ja
mehrere Epochen auch in Hamburg und ich
war lefun und da lief richtig da war
richtig so ein DJ so mit Glatze und der
hat richtig so rare Grove Funk auf das
gibt's in Berlin gar nicht das macht
kein Mensch also zumindest gibt's
natürlich Kneipen aber da sitzt keiner
drin und die warammel voll die Kneipe da
das das ist einfach das ist in mich also
das ist in mir ich find's gut also ich
find es quasi noch nicht mal ja 90er ist
noch nicht so richtig finde ich wüsste
ich gar nicht wie das klingen sollte
oder was jetzt so wie ich das machen
sollte ich wollte eigentlich eine
gemeine Frage haben ja die ist doch
gemein oder nicht na ja so gemein war
die gar nicht von ich dachte jetzt kommt
irgendwas irgendwie horrormäßiges
horrormäßiges was hast du jetzt zum Teil
sind eure Texte richtig
gesellschaftskritisch und zum Teil genau
das Gegenteil ja was denn n ja also ich
würde eher sagen wir machen Tourette Pop
und super okay Tourette ballett ist
unsere Show und das wird einfach
rausgebrüllt und wir wollen einfach
ja wir machen was den N was den N ja was
den N irgendwie
groß oder klein oder unten oder oben
oder es ist mir egal was den N ne ich ma
tette und ich möchte bitte als
minderbemittelter Mensch möchte ich
bitte akzeptiert werden von der
Gesellschaft so wie die Menschen mit
Down Syndrom haben auch eine eigene
Werkstatt wo sie irgendwie hingehen mit
ihrem Aktenkoffer und die C CV gibt's ja
nicht mehr und ich habe hier meine Show
okay du sagst alle Menschen sind
behindert ich auch genau ich vorne weg
okay du vorne weg aber wat den nur heißt
ja auch oder toret Syndrom ist woll
nicht irgendwie so so Gesamtpaket sein
so viele kstler denken ja das muss ja
das ist nee das ist mE nicht mein Image
und das ist nicht mein
Image ganze wenn so jemand wir gehen
sowieso davon aus dass wir durchstrahlt
werden von der mus und der Kreativität
und wir sind überhaupt keine Typen die
sich hinstellen und sagen ich bin der
Künstler ich setze mich in der Jury weil
ich habe es geschafft irgendwie so ich
bin das Genie das ist alles Bullshit
also wir sind erstmal sind wir
austauschbar alle und zweitens kochen
wir mit Wasser genauso wie okay dr voice
oder oder der Gewinner von xfaktor 7 gut
sehr gut meine Ansicht auch ich kenne
keinen der mit Champagner kocht schmeckt
ja auch nicht nee schmeckt schmeckt noch
nicht doch habe ich letztens ja ja
Cherry Tomaten 500 g und 500
ml Champagner und eine knoblazehe und
das richtig durch köcheln und dann mit
Nudeln ein Traum so ich lese mal vor ihr
tragt bei eurer Show immer tetraeda auf
dem Kopf findet ihr euch so hässlich
dass ihr eure Gesichter nicht zeigen
wollt nee es geht darum dass wir
m dass wir auch gerne z.B mit der
Straßenbahn mit der Straßenbahn fahren
wir auch gerne mal zum Studio und das
ist dann wirklich auch ganz angenehm
weil z.B Ferres der später dazuekommen
ist zu uns das ist ja eine richtige berü
der ist richtig berühmt wenn wir da bei
Subways oder bei McDonald's anhalten mit
Nightliner dann wird er immer nach
Autogrammen gefragt und so weiter und
das ist natürlich auch angenehm aber ich
find es auch recht angenehm einfach so
mal durch ein Park zu gehen und dann
ohne dass man erkannt wird wir sind halt
auch immer freundlich zu den Leuten also
feris wird dann auch gerne handgreiflich
oder spuckt oh und wir sind halt immer
freundlich Z le die sind dann immer wenn
die uns mal erkennen sind die auch sehr
schnell
sind die drehen die sich sehr schnell
wieder weg weil so Star der freundlich
ist und nett ist das ist ja total
langweilig e aber ist nicht auch
Hintergr dass sagt he das ist ja wie die
BL GRP das Ken wir ja mal skalieren und
K habon das ist quasi auch unser Vorbild
also Leute wie blan Group oder oder klim
globotters das sind so Leute die die uns
wirklich immer im zu den wireschaut
haben
Lordi so Bands zu den wir hochgeschaut
haben also wir wollen ja eigentlich
auch hat er sich nicht aufgehängt mury
ne t Gerücht glaube ich also der ist nur
auf Twitter gestorben ja das ist ja
total bescheuert irgendwie ne also
bisher ist er nur auf Twitter gestorben
vielleicht hol die ich fand den auch gut
ne aber ist das so ein Hintergrund ist
es eine Idee malmer zu sagen auch später
können wir das mal irgendwie nee wir
wollen ja eigentlich auch immer wir
wollen eigentlich auchmer so eine
Franchise ein Franchise Unternehmen
entwickeln und tolle Idee aber schwer
umsetzbar wirklich schwer umsetzbar aber
es ist wir sind wir bleiben dran wir
müssen jetzt bloß noch mal die A7 rauf
und runter Deutschland Österreich
Schweiz Touren das ist nimmt viel Zeit
in Anspruch aber aber da vielleicht 2014
Fang fangen wir damit an wirklich also
das diese Frage wie seid ihr auf
originale bühnensch gekommen das ist die
gleiche Antwort elich wie bei der
anderen das ist wirklich stüper Scheiße
die einfach jede bescheute Idee wird
einfach durchgezogen und je blöder dass
du und deswegen kommt das irgendwie so
rüber als wäre das so genial aber
eigentlich sind wir sttimper die
großkotzige Kleinkunst
machen also wir wollen die nächste Frage
so hochgefickt ja also ihr hat sich
perfekt es war wirklich erst m ja aber
stimperei kann ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen weil irgendwie muss es ja was
haben es muss ja irgendwie ja aber
eigenlub stinkt hier kann ich ja noch
mal gebt zu eure aufwendige Show macht
ihr nur um von der mittelmäßigen Musik a
abzulenken oder da habt ihr natürlich
vollkommen Recht und ins Mark getroffen
also wir wir die ganze Show da
verstecken wir uns selber wir wir wollen
gar nicht zeigen was für Genies wir
eigentlich sind auf eigentlich im
eigentlichen Leben seid ihr Finanzbeamte
ich bin elektroinstallat du bist Elektro
arbeitet auch so und das ist eigentlich
euch total peinlich was ihr hier macht
genau genau es ist auch wirklich man
manchmal ist man auf der Bühne und
schämt sich richtig man ist richtig so
man steht da und denkt oh Gott was
denken die Leute jetzt hier eigentlich
gerade von mir aber die Feier natürlich
ab aber man selber denkt so ah irgendwie
ich glaube ich wäre jetzt lieber zu
Hause und würde Fernsehen gucken und ist
es ehrlich so ist es manchmal so das
oder ist es Keil auf der Bühne ist ist
ein zwi schizopren da sein weil man ist
natürlich auch Rampensau
und deswegen geht man immer wieder drauf
aber dann merkt man wieder oh Gott was
sitzt man dann zu Hause und dann
und dann will man doch wieder es ist
also wirklich schizophrenes da sein wie
so eine Droge man kann nicht mit und man
kann nicht ohne ja genau deswegen hat ha
Haard Caren auch schon zum siebten Mal
sein sein Ende eingereicht und ist den
doch wieder weil die Alde nervt
irgendwann zu
Hause okay also wie schafft ihr es euch
immer wieder neu zu erfinden wir machen
wir eigentlich gar nicht also Deich
kindind verändert sich immer automatisch
wir machen eigentlich gar nichts also
das passiert irgendwie automatisch
irgendwi so diesen Klamotten hier das
ist auch neu neuer shit den haben wir
gestern in so 99 Cent Laden gekauft
schön haben die gekostet echtes Gold
echtes Gold ah ja ist schön im Cent
Laden sensationell super hab Lady Gaga
mäßig ein Outfit wei du wie schafft es
die Lady Gaga immer wieder neu zu
erfinden die zockt sich ihre Scheiße bei
Youtube zusammen weiß du hängt dann auf
einmal Video mit Bierdosen am Kopf
gegaffert wo hat sie das
Woher
ja
ich sag mal die Zigaretten hat sie ganz
klar von euch ne hat ich nur gedacht
hier bieldosen kann ich auch mit
Zigaretten die ist auch bestimmt
manchmal genert von i Song hängt in
japanf ich will endlich Backstage in die
Nase ziehen die könn auch mal ich finde
auch sowieso die Mucke von der ich finde
das Lady Gaga alles cool ich find Lady
Gaga Fan ne lieber Fan von Lady Gaga
jetzt fü dich nicht angef aber diese
letzte i'm on the edge das klingt
irgendwie als würden da zwei Playbacks
übereinander laufen weiß auch nicht so
eine geheime Botschaft oder so aber
trotzdem ein ein Künstlerin sind sowieso
gerade so eine Diven Hype hier was ich
macht das ist letztlich wie wie ihr das
ein riesen Gesamtkunstwerk und
wahnsinnig gut aufgezogen ich will jetzt
auch gar nicht über Lady Gager herziehen
das würde mich auch verletzen wenn
jemand Überich herzieht lst uns über
Deichkind Herzen und die letzte rote
Frage beantworten ja genau ist eure
Musik nicht total stumpfsinnig stumpf
ist Trumpf würde den man jetzt sagen ja
hast du es ist natürlich Stumpfsinn ist
da drin das ist aber auch so ein
bisschen auch so geplant also das ist ja
da hast du recht also der Primat Pochert
ja im jben irendie und wir bedienen uns
gerne an den
lumpenproletariats Zuckung die in jedem
schwing und je stumpfer das ist do mehr
scht mit mehr schminkt es mit stumpsin
macht auch Spaß einfach leider geil wenn
ich z wenn ich z.B so eine Mappe Krieg
zu Hause bei mir unten im Keller in
meinem Labor wenn ich dann irgendwie so
Arbeiten von Studenten auswerten muss
dann bin ich da
weißag du bist Elektroinstallateur na
ich bin ja auch Chemie Dozent ah ja okay
Sinus Alpha gleich gegen kathet durch
hypetenuse und dann hat er da irgendwie
ein Komma vergessen und dann bin ich da
mein Kopf quimt und dann brauche ich das
einfach zu diesem stumpfsin okay gut in
diesem Sinne noch viel stumpf sind von
euch willst du zum Ende noch mal drehen
oder oh ja komm wir drehen zum Ende noch
mal komm dreh noch
mal meine sehr verhten D undent hi
feres tachchen
willst du dich willst du dich noch fürs
letzte dazu
setzen komm jetzt müssen wir nämlich was
haben
wir 15 Liegestütze Band hey
555 wir sehen
deichkend am
Boden oh synchron
Liegestützen mit Philip und
fer ah nee zu dritt vi
vi 5
6 7
[Musik]
12 13 muss mal kurz hier
[Applaus]
sensationell
Hammer